>> ALBERTO NAVA: I mean, you're always looking
for something new to discover, but we
didn't know what we were going to find when
we started on that day.
Most of our dives are pretty routine, you
know, you just keep finding more tunnels and
more tunnels.
But every so often you get lucky and you run
into these discoveries that have been trapped
there for thousands of years.
We just pop up into this huge void.
It's like if you entered the Grand Canyon
from the side at night.
Everywhere you point your light, there were
animal remains, there were
human remains.
It was just a pretty good day.
Eventually my friend points his light toward
this cranium, and all of a sudden we discover
the most complete and the oldest human remains
found in the Americas.
Imagine the pressure if somebody says, "Okay,
you go pick up the cranium of the oldest human
remains in America." Your hands start shaking.
You know, what happens if you drop it?
You know, you're underwater and you're
looking at this cranium and you see these
dark eye sockets.
I have this feeling these eyes have not seen
anything since thousands of years ago.
You're kind of traveling back in time.
In the case of Naia, we have most of her skeleton.
The more amazing thing is that you still have
intact DNA that researchers can extract from.
So that helps you figure out the migration
history from humans into the Americas.
When we go into this cave, we think that we're
doing this great exploration, but in reality,
the original explorers of this cave were Naia
and her people.
When I have a bad day, either in the jungle
or at home, I compare it with what they struggle.
. . to go and find water, and food, and shelter,
every day.
And they have to fight animals.
You know, they have the saber-toothed cat.
So for me it's easy—if I have a problem,
I just think about them and I'm like, oh,
my problem, it's not very big.
[laughs]
Hoyo Negro and Naia are the stars of this
project, and we all work to bring their stories
light so we understand a little bit better
about where do we come from.